in Washington there's lobbying and then
there's lobbying the 44 billion dollar
proposed merger between Comcast and Time
Warner Cable is an exercise in lobbying
Comcast has spent 18 million eight
hundred ten thousand dollars in lobbying
last year that's more than any other
company for defense contractor north of
chromatin a lot of that money went
straight into the campaign coffers of
politicians fifty nine thousand dollars
to John Boehner thirty seven thousand to
Mitch McConnell twenty seven thousand to
Greg Walden twenty five but the real
power in Washington is often visibly
pick this guy former Navy SEAL Neil
Smith Neil Smith is a CEO of comcast
Cable but he's also the chairman of the
national cable and Telecommunications
Association
NCTA gave me a thousand dollars in
lobbying last year much of it going to
the same politicians the Comcast
contributed to that made it the top five
lobbyists in all of Washington DC last
and before Smits chairman of the MTA was
Tom wheeler where's he now
well President Obama naming the chairman
of the FCC the very body that will
decide the fate
and for any one of the FCC thinking
about their next job
welcome to the FCC Michael Powell is now
the CEO of the NCTA
and Meredith Baker an FCC Commissioner
who helped approve the Comcast NBC deal
well she left the FCC to go to Comcast
as their chief lobbyist
she's one of 107 lobbyists we're trying
to use all of Comcast's power influence
and money to urge Washington to accept
this deal